madame la présidente mes chers collègues
madame le garde des sceaux pas un mois
ne passe sans que la sécurité de nos
établissements bénigne ans hier ne soit
évoqué dans les médias au parlement ou
par vous même madame la mission de
sécurité de l'administration
pénitentiaire consiste à assumer des
sécurité optimale dans les prisons en
prévenant les évasions les mutineries
les violences les dégradations ou les
suicides
sa mission est aussi de prévoir la
réinsertion des condamnés à leur sortie
pour éviter la récidive depuis 2015 le
contexte terroriste a naturellement
accentuer cette exigence de sécurité et
nous oblige à une vigilance accrue
l'agression des trois surveillants
souvenez-vous à vendin-le-vieil en
janvier dernier par un détenu condamné
pour terrorisme fut à l'origine un grand
mouvement de mobilisation du personnel
pénitentiaire il nous faut à toutes fins
qu'il ne se re déclenche pas les
surveillants qui je voudrais rendre
hommage nous ont alertés très souvent
sur leurs conditions de travail
particulièrement difficiles sur le
manque de personnel qui les expose
dangereusement pendant l'exercice de
leurs missions et sur les difficultés à
recruter de nouveaux collègues
la surpopulation continue à dégrader la
vie carcérale et pèse sur les conditions
de sécurité de nos établissements
pénitentiaires l'été a été difficile
dans de nombreux endroits de france
il y faisait il faisait très chaud dans
les maisons d'arrêt au sens propre comme
au sens figuré
la semaine dernière je suis allé visiter
la prison de la santé avec quelques
collègues sénateurs
les syndicats de surveillants nous
exposer à nouveau leur mécontentement et
leur crainte
le manque de reconnaissance face à aux
difficultés de leurs missions qu'ils
exercent c'est surtout ça qui revient
très souvent une nouvelle promotion de
surveillants devrait assumer assurer
l'ouverture de la prison de la santé
beaucoup de ces personnes venues de
l'outre-mer n'ont toujours pas trouvé de
logement décent à prix raisonnable pour
pouvoir s'installer à paris certains
surveillants stagiaires ont trouvé des
solutions d'hébergement précaire
notamment dans les foyers de jeunes
travailleurs d'autres sont toujours en
cours de recherche
tous réclament des lieux de détente de
sport pour évacuer la pression
quotidienne et pour saint s'entraîner
physiquement c'est bien le moins que
l'on puisse leur offrir
quand on sait la quantité de menaces de
représailles qui subissent chaque jour
le sénateur grosdidier lors de nos
travaux de la commission d' enquête sur
l'état des forces de sécurité intérieure
l'avait souligné dans le rapport que
nous avions produit à chaque visite de
maison d'arrêt ce que d'un frêne et
cetera nous sentons l'attention et les
craintes professionnels peser dans la
vie de chacun et je voulais vous en
faire part madame je sais que vous les
connaissez mais c'est ici au sénat nous
y prenons particulièrement attention
contexte terrorisme surpopulation
carcérale mécontentement des
surveillants ces trois ingrédients
format cocktail explosif qui ne peut que
nuire à la mission de sécurité de
l'administration pénitentiaire
madame le garde des sceaux les
orientations voulues par votre ministère
nous semble pas suffisamment prendre en
compte ces trois facteurs d'insécurité
votre ministère va-t-il aller plus loin
avez vous les moyens budgétaires pour
garantir la sécurité de nos
établissements
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
merci madame la présidente messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames les sénatrice yonah
la sénatrice il me faudrait plus d'une
heure pour vous répondre
tant les l'ensemble des mesures que nous
avons adoptées et qui vise à la fois
assurer la sécurité de nos
établissements pénitentiaires mais
également la reconnaissance puisque vous
avez utilisé ce terme je reprends à mon
compte la reconnaissance que nous devons
aux personnels de l'administration
pénitentiaire est grande
quelques chiffres simplement le budget
de l'administration pénitentiaire
s'élève à 3 8 milliards d'euros au plf
2010 9 soit 2,5 milliards pour les
dépenses de personnel c'est en hausse de
95 millions d'euros et 1,2 milliard pour
les autres dépenses
ce budget globalement est en progression
de 5 7% par rapport à la loi de finances
initiale de 2018 c'est une augmentation
qui correspond à la fois à une hausse
des dépenses de personnel de 3,9 pour
cent et à une hausse de près de 10 %
pour les dépenses de fonctionnement et
d'investissement dans sept chiffres
dans cet énoncé des chiffres je n'irai
pas au delà car vous pourriez vous
lasser mais je voudrais ici vous dire
que la sécurisation des établissements
pénitentiaires est un point majeur
nous y consacrons un effort important de
plus de 50 millions d'euros en 2019 et
au delà pour les personnels
pénitentiaires pour lesquelles je le
redis ici j'ai une véritable
reconnaissance en raison des conditions
très difficiles d'exercice de leur
travail
nous avons fait un effort du point de
vue indemnitaire en haussant la pss de
plus de 2% en augmentant le taux de base
de l'indemnité pour charge pénitentiaire
la faisant passer de 1000 à 1400 euros
par an en augmentant la prime des
dimanches et jours fériés de 26 à 36
euros en mettant en place une prime de
fait de fidélisation pour les
établissements les plus difficiles ou
dans des zones de particulière cherté du
coût de la vie c'est le cas en banlieue
parisienne où nous donnerons 8000 euros
pour six ans de fidélité un
établissement quatre mille euros seront
versés dès la première année nous avons
fait un effort important en terme de
matériel avec des nouveaux matériels de
protection en termes d'équipement de
passes menottes etc
nous avons fait un effort en termes de
renseignements pénitentiaire nous avons
fait un effort en termes de régime de
détention avec la mise en place d'un
système d'étanchéité pour les détenus
les plus dangereux les détenus
terroristes
et tout cela s'inscrit dans un plan
pénitentiaire globale qui prévoit à
hauteur de plus d'un milliard sept la
construction de quinze mille nouvelles
places de prison dont 7000 seront livrés
en 2022 et 8000 seront commencés avant
je crois que c'est cet ensemble de
mesures qui nous permet de répondre à
l'inquiétude dont vous faisiez état et
dont je mesure qu'elle est réelle